so in the last week we had a white
supremacist attack a grocery store we
had assassination attempts with pipe
bombs against past presidents and dozens
of a and a dozen others rather roughly a
dozen total I guess in the interest of
being precise and accurate we had an
anti-semitic right-wing shooter killed
more than 10 at a synagogue everything
has been backwards in terms of the
reactions the department of homeland
security secretary Kristen Nielsen was
at the border fear-mongering about
unarmed children who are starving and
walking through Mexico a thousand miles
away pretending that that's actually the
problem and actually the threat to
national security in the United States
the reactions have been as crass and
ignorant as they have been dangerous and
depraved Donald Trump was asked about
the synagogue shooting and he was asked
about gun laws and he said the problem
isn't with the gun laws it's that the
synagogue didn't have more security you
have any questions
well again this has little to do with it
if you take a look if they had
protection inside the results would have
been far better this is a dispute that
will always exist I suspect but if they
had some kind of a protection inside the
temple maybe it could have been a very
much different situation this is sort of
a victim blaming Oh a rape took place
that's horrible we need to do something
to stop rapists from raping no the
victim should have been armed and
focusing on that side of the problem
makes absolutely no sense it's a
distraction
it's disgusting and then Trump went on
to say that we should actually have more
of the death penalty we should have more
death penalty a wacko I think one thing
we should do is we should stiffen up our
laws in terms of the death penalty when
people do this they should get the death
penalty and they shouldn't have to wait
years and years now the lawyers will get
involved and everybody's going to get
involved it will be ten years down the
line and I think they should step it up
stiffen up laws and I think they should
very much bring the death penalty and
devote this is truly one of the dumbest
things to say period states with the
death penalty don't have less violent
crime anyway but getting rid of appeals
in order to execute people more quickly
is not going to be a deterrent and in
fact in my death penalty debate I did at
another show last week or the week
before I talked about this that once you
have a sort of reasonable punishment
once the punishment is reasonable enough
for an infraction what really matters in
terms of deterrence is how likely you
are to get caught the example is
jaywalking if there is a ten dollar fine
if you get caught jaywalking and a
hundred dollar fine if you get caught
jaywalking going to the hundred dollar
fine doesn't actually seem to have a
deterrent deterrent effect what does is
how likely are you to get a fine at all
for jaywalking if it's very likely you
will be caught and fine for jaywalking
the ten dollar fine appears to be just
as effective as the hundred dollar fine
and likewise when it comes to murder
if you believe that you are likely to be
caught if you commit a murder the
difference between the potential for
life in prison and the potential for the
death penalty does not have the
deterrent effect that defenders of the
death penalty have and of course Trump
has absolutely no idea then we get to
Sean Hannity on Fox News Hannity did
condemn the magg a bomber and then
almost immediately started attacking the
left which is part of the rhetoric that
is getting people to go out and actually
do these things take a listen and like
the president said we want anybody
anybody responsible for this heinous
bomb scare to be held responsible to the
fullest extent of the law
if seoc is found guilty he should go to
prison for an extremely long period of
time these actions are deplorable
inexcusable there is no room for
political violence in this country
calling it a bomb scare you will know it
also makes it less serious and then he
just tears in to the left the same old
stuff we solve our problems like an 11
days at the ballot box and as as I've
said many times is a very serious story
but over the course of this week well we
have seen well we have witnessed in the
mainstream media and the left has been
downright disgraceful before ever even
knowing who was responsible for this
heinous act the media started playing
the blame game rushing to judgment as
usual they put facts last they rushed to
judgment and they did anything in
everything possible to link President
Trump and anyone who supports him to
this act of terrorism
20 seconds between condemning the act
and participating in the type of stuff
that causes exactly more of these acts
also strangely some people are emailing
me that Sean Hannity's face has gotten
huge I don't know if anybody else
noticed that but I did notice that I
don't know what's up with that and then
one other example here's Kelly Anne
Conway pretending that the attack on the
synagogue is anti religiosity not
anti-semitism take a look keep reading
them Ainsley and I know you understand
this very well is the anti religiosity
in this country that it's somehow in
vogue and funny
to make fun of anybody of faith to
constantly be making fun of people who
express religion the late-night
comedians the unfunny people on TV shows
it's always anti religious and remember
these people are gunned down in their
place of worship really dangerous
because they want you to believe that
the synagogue attack is the same as the
non-existent war on Christianity when
the big difference is that anti-semitism
is real and what's really important is
that all of these incidents we've been
talking about our domestic terror the
right slammed Obama and the left for not
using the term radical Islamic terror I
would use it when it applies I use it I
called ducks ducks not something else
well along the same lines we have to
call this right-wing domestic terrorism
it's inspired by ideologies that have
been emboldened by the current president
imagine if in the same two-week span we
had Isis attacking people in a grocery
store in the United States
sending mail bombs to twelve Republicans
and killing ten people in a mass
shooting at a Christian Church does
anybody believe that the reactions would
be Church should have been better
protected the political climate has
nothing to do with it the White House
doesn't need to do anything period does
anyone believe that the reaction would
be the same if you do you're either
disingenuous or you're ignorant and I
want to hear from you on Twitter at D
Pakman on the shows Twitter account
david pakman show quick break back after
this I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka steaks the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the
day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli n
ki st.com /pa ke ma n